are you looking forward to resident evil
7 if you're excited enough to pre-order
it you'll get some decent bonuses I'm
Tony and this is your horrifying
gamespot news update we already know
that pre-ordering resident evil 7
unlocks the hardest difficulty early and
gets you an item pack but Swedish
retailer disc shop may have leaked
images of that pack pictures on the site
show a recovery set with green herbs a
handgun set with some ammo boxes a chem
fluid set with what appear to be healing
items and a burner set which may be
linked to the previously leaked
flamethrower weapon each pack also shows
a mysterious gold coin we've contacted
Capcom for more information on the leak
resident evil 7 hits ps4 xbox one and pc
on january twenty four twenty seventeen
and speaking of bonuses anyone who
pre-orders the $80 deluxe edition will
get two more pieces of content or short
side stories and a bonus chapter for the
main game to keep up with all the
biggest Resident Evil news or to watch
us play through the whole series you're
already in the right place
you